statt
St
SID SID
Rumms
Prof SID
Satz
St St
es ist nichts
es ist ist St 1
zur Post Ast
das passt
SID
St SID
dpa
St
ist es ist so
SID
offensichtlich
St
SID St
Ernst Spiel
ist
St
es ist
Hallo Lilli Chillida eine Legende bei
den fünf Renntagen bei Baidu hatte eine
er
Nürburg Frage da ich mag Prozent sagen
an Prozent kommt nur gestellt die
Arbeiter
er und ich bin auch zum Teil einiges ab
ich hab da so ein paar Prozent um
Motivationsfaktor etwas was ein nicht so
ganz ich motiviere über die Kunden
demotiviert werden lässt wenn es ganz
schlimm kommt und Walter Kainz Prozent
das hat man die Leiterin des Nachwuchs
derart das Sprungbrett zu mir gesagt und
ich will damit hat sie recht das war so
vom WDR hier so Nachwuchs dienen würde
man dabei war Provo Bremens Prozent ganz
hierher kommen Hape Kerkeling ist er
groß geworden
um Aaron Wolff Lück und noch viele
andere so Paare auf
die hat zu mir gesagt gut dass man wenn
man
wenn man voll arisiert das heißt wenn
an 50 Prozent richtig Scheiße finden
und 50 Prozent richtig gut das heißt
und das ist meistens der Fall
häufig lohnt Daumen drückt um der ist
ist das Schlimmste ist wenn 50 Prozent
negativ den Unternehmen Erhebung normal
dass 2 Interview polarisiert auch der
Gast Maloney ich mal je nachdem was es
ist das ist gut und das denken auch
immer bei denen elf Kommentaren Prozent
und das zweite ist natürlich er hatte
tolle hat das meistens mal gesagt und
das stimmt auch ein bisschen Peter sind
Prozent wie Bibel Schmirgelpapier ja
nicht ob ich die
die machen die ich im Kopf bleiben wir
als Rohdiamanten ein
der glitzernden brillanten um Prozent
das heißt man lernt viel auch aus der
negativen Kritik und Prozent jeder hält
er guckt auch das Video ist also ein Wii
u
also hat auch etwas positives
letztlich und das ist das wichtige bei
der Motivation man muss immer das
positive aus einem Rücksetzer ziehen
das Marienbad werden
wie überall im Leben ich zieh aus allem
das positive weil alle fast alles er hat
etwas positives und Prozent enorm unsere
finden so oder so ist er ist die Fragen
Jahren
warum ich immer die und kreativen Frage
nehmen also Essener niemand ihn aber
damit nicht die abschieben sondern wir
versuchen nach bestem wissen und
gewissen die besten Fragen auszusuchen
lieber mal daneben Sicherheit
Geschmäcker sind verschieden
wer Irland ist menschlich aber wir
versuchen die besten Fragen
so Prozent ziehen also wenn du mal
wieder und so will ist einfach und
schreiben oder ihr könnt ja auch ich
weiß nicht was also
Bewerbungen bitte zu tun
mehr geht nicht
also als das beste versuchen das beste
zu machen ist Prozent einig unmöglich
soviel dazu